إنه أحد الوجوه الأكثر شهرة
في هوليوود ، لكن براد بيت يقول إنه
يكافح لتذكر وجوه الآخرين ،
ويعتقد البالغ من العمر 58 عامًا أنه
يعاني من عمى التعرف على الوجوه أو يواجه
العمى ، ويواجهون تحديات في
القدرة على التعرف على الوجوه المألوفة مثل
أفراد الأسرة الذين
يمكنهم المشي دون قصد
من قبل أحد أفراد الأسرة كما لو لم
يسبق لهم رؤيتها من قبل في الأماكن العامة
حيث توجد وجوه متعددة قد يواجه
أولئك الذين يعانون من هذا
الاضطراب العصبي صعوبة في
الانتباه أثناء محادثة أو قد
لا يتمكنون من متابعة شخصيات مختلفة
أثناء مشاهدة فيلم يقول
طبيب الأعصاب في كليفلاند كلينك  الدكتور أندريه ستوجيك
يمكن أن يخلق
الارتباك والارتباك في بعض الأحيان
للناس
ويمكن أن يتفاقم بعد ذلك بمجرد
تطوير
القلق الاجتماعي والشخصي
بسبب عدم القدرة على التفاعل
مع الناس ، لا يزال البحث جارياً
لفهم الاضطراب
وأسبابه ولكن ستوجيك يقول ذلك  يمكن أن تبدأ
عند الولادة أو تتطور بمرور الوقت لا يوجد
ج  لكن يمكن للمرضى الحصول على علاج
للمساعدة في التعرف على الآخرين بطرق مختلفة
قد تنظر إلى البالغين وقد
تنظر إلى الطريقة التي يقفون بها أو
وضعهم بالطريقة التي يمشون بها شخصًا
يعرفونه لديه تسريحة شعر محددة جدًا
قد يكونون قادرين على ربط ذلك  هذا
الشخص ومن ثم يتم تنبيهه بذلك عندما
يواجه هذا الشخص للدقيقة الصحية
أنا ماندي غايثر